celebrating the holy month of ramadan
in the ruins
tariq abu ziyad and his family fasted
from dawn until dusk
and now they're breaking that fast in
what was once
their home a splash of color
in a sea of crushed concrete abusive
says
he fled his home in ariha at the end of
the year when the syrian army and the
russians
bombed this area
now my family and i are here on top of
the destruction
we are reliving a very difficult and
painful memory
i pray that god doesn't let anyone else
experience this
his mother says with the kitchen
destroyed they brought ready meals from
outside
the most important thing is that we
relive our memories and eat in our home
ariha is situated in idlib province a
few kilometers west
of the strategic m5 highway
held for years by rebel forces it was
the major target for the syrian
government
to capture during an offensive in
december
nearly a million people were displaced
by the violence
most fled north arriving at the turkish
border
where many live in makeshift camps
a recent u.n report says in 2019 syria
had the largest number of new
displacements of any country
almost 1.9 million the situation for
displaced people living at the border
was
dire when a ceasefire was agreed between
russia and turkey in march
tens of thousands of people returned to
their homes
some like abusiad's family found them
completely destroyed
but many found it easier to live amongst
the ruins
rather than return to the camps laura
about a manly al jazeera